you did something that I like valve to
never do again because this is a very
hard thing to do
i-i've sang at a few funerals in my life
and it's just the hardest scenario ever
if you know them or if you don't it
doesn't matter because you're seeing
other people's pain regardless and it's
just painful
you actually performed a george florence
funeral so here he did involved I
believe that the family reached out I
got I got the information from from my
manager so I didn't but I believe they
reached out an axe if I were if I would
sing and I mean of course I said yeah so
we got down there um I I tried to sit a
little further back you know because I
didn't want I didn't want the moment to
be about me at all you know what I mean
like I didn't want to do the celebrity
thing I don't want but the way they saw
me they pulled me up to it to a close-up
you know so I'm sitting there and I get
up on stage and the second I got up
there I looking at anything his daughter
sitting right in front and and and then
all I can see in that moment with my
daughter and it broke broke I couldn't I
couldn't hardest thing to do yes I can't
I couldn't give my words together or
what I wanted to say that came out wrong
some people misunderstood what I meant
by that but I know that's that's kind of
the breath thing twos I feel like I
heard there was a bit of blowback from
the funeral what did that hit you hard
like to where you were like wait that
was totally missed that I got that was
twisted you know it's in Italy
I want my initially it did cuz I'll be
honest when I my manager called me and
told me about what was being said or
whatever and I instantly got upset like
like what like how could anybody really
think that I would stand up at this
man's funeral in front of this man's
family and mean anything negative or
wrong about like how could anybody make
that mistake right so I got upset and my
response was you know what intelligent
people know what I meant yeah and
anybody ignorant ain't worried about it
but then but then my manager had catch
me he was like no that's not what this
is this moment is really really really
important okay the least you could do is
take a few minutes to make sure that
people understand what it is you're
saying
okay because ignorance is division and
we don't need division right now all
right we need to do this right yeah
that's it so so take a second explain
what it is you meant not because you not
because anyone is owed an explanation
but because it's the right thing to do
in order for unity to be part of the
merrier not not division you know so I
took it upon myself I went into the
comics and I answer some people somebody
said he wasn't sacrificed he was
murdered and I'm like okay well in the
realm of a lot of sacrifices they kind
of involved death
I mean it's unfortunate it's unfortunate
that his death was the spark that caused
this energy that is slowly but surely
creating change for us but the truth of
the matter is this man's life was
sacrificed in order for this to happen
now I don't think that was the car that
was the reasoning behind it initially of
course cops killed him and it was meant
for it was wicked it was meant for
wicked but we then took something that
was meant for wicked and turned it into
a positive
ya know III agree subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going